[Musik]
zusammen mit meinen kollegen der
landtagsfraktion der freien demokraten
haben wir beschlossen die auflösung des
thüringer landtages zu beantragen
damit möchten wir neuwahlen herbeiführen
um damit den markt die unterstützung
durch die efsa vom amt des
ministerpräsidenten zu nehmen
und deshalb habe ich zu einer
sondersitzung unseres parteivorstands am
morgen mittag in berlin eingeladen und
ich beabsichtige auf dieser
sondersitzung des parteivorstandes die
vertrauensfrage zu stellen
chaostage in erfurt ein
ministerpräsident 24 stunden zuvor
gewählt schon wieder auf dem abflug der
chef der bundes fdp spürbar angeschlagen
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
die politischen wirren von erfurt gehen
in die nächste runde und es steckt viel
grundsätzliches darin wie halten es die
parteien der mitte mit demokratie
feinden mit rechtsaußen die sich mehr
oder weniger offen fremdenfeindlich und
antisemitisch zeigen
fdp und cdu haben mit dem feuer gespielt
das aber immerhin schnell wieder
ausgetreten
was heißt das alles für die
bundespolitik und für die demokratie
daniel pontzen aus berlin wie weit die
schockwellen reichten die gestern das
politische berlin durch zuckten wie sich
heute weit von mir entfernt spüren ein
wort halte zurück aus südafrika ein wort
der kanzlerin in seltener schärfe
nach dem gestrigen dammbruch hatten
schon über nacht hektisch die
reparaturarbeiten begonnen bei beiden
beschädigten parteien cdu und fdp
jeweils mit hinweis auf den anderen ein
blame game offenbar unwichtige halten
scheinlich auch nicht den durchgriff in
thüringen also in thüringen gehabt dass
die fdp vor ort sich davon hätte
abstellen lassen wir als freie
demokraten haben die situation geklärt
das erwarten wir nun auch von der union
ein kenner ich musste eine nacht
schlafen über diese entscheidung und die
situation das sieht schon ja die alte
preußische beschwerde ordnung vor
die preußische beschwerde ordnung sie
sie tatsächlich vorerst mal eine nacht
überschlafen etwas mehr nachdenken in
den nächten zuvor hätte gut getan sagen
derweil kritische beobachter vor allem
mit blick auf die demokratische statik
denn trotz der heutigen
rettungsmaßnahmen ein schaden bleiben
das ist gewissermaßen art vertrauens
vernichtung von politik und demokratie
das ist ja sehr viel mehr als die frage
ob ein einzelner politiker da mal einen
fehler gemacht hat oder damals
zurücktritt und das ganze wieder
zurückzunehmen und so weiter das hat
eine andere dimension
und sie werden erleben dass uns das über
etliche jahre weiter in erinnerung
bleibt
schafer tadel kommt auch aus der elder
statesman riege der fdp selbst samt
historischen vergleich es ist nicht nur
die af den parlamenten diese denke sitzt
auch kommt aus dem inneren der bürger
also einer einer mittelschicht aus
teilen des bürgertums und das hat mich
veranlasst zu sagen es ist ein hauch von
weimar gibt es neben den vielen
verlieren auch gewinne ja jene die eine
zerreißprobe der demokratie wollen und
was sagt heute die afd
wieso ein solches ergebnis zu rückgängig
gemacht werden muss von der
bundeskanzlerin ist mir
demokratietheoretisch nicht begreifbar
ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen die
neuwahl ist die bedingungen dafür der
vorgang den sie jetzt erleben konnten
ist das gravierende so haben echte
erdbeben und politische eines gemeinen
meist reichen für massiven schaden
wenige dramatische minuten der
wiederaufbau dauert dann mitunter viele
jahre in düsseldorf begrüße ich den
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
der fdp im bundestag alexander graf
lambsdorff guten abend schön würden
abend kommando zurück hieß es heute in
erfurt ein kapitaler politischer fehler
ist korrigiert worden mit viel druck von
außen und offenkundig wenig einsicht bei
den handelnden vor ort was ist da denn
schief gelaufen in ihrer partei ich
glaube dass wir hier nicht die
gesamtpartei in haftung nehmen dürfen
sondern der landesverband thüringen
entscheidet diese dinge autonom und was
schief gelaufen ist kann man sehr
konkret festmachen
thomas kemmerich wollte ein symbol
setzen dass es auch einen demokratischen
kandidaten gibt aber als er dann gewählt
worden ist mit stimmen von und
demokraten antidemokraten da hat er die
wahl angenommen anstatt sie
auszuschlagen ich glaube das war der
fehler den sie eben erwähnt haben und
der ist jetzt glücklicherweise
korrigiert worden
es gab ja ein austausch zwischen dem
thüringer landesvorsitzende der fdp und
parteichef lindner schon tage vor der
heftig kritisierten wahl wer trägt denn
er trägt denn eigentlich politisch die
verantwortung nur herr kemmerich oder
doch auch christian lindner
sie dürfen sich ja der partei und das
gilt für alle parteien nicht vorstellen
werden unternehmen wo oben ein chef
sitzt und quasi abteilungsleitern
anweisungen erteilt im gegenteil es
läuft genau umgekehrt die bundes
parteien bestehen aus den
landesverbänden und die entscheiden
autonomen wir regieren wir
beispielsweise als freie demokraten in
schleswig-holstein rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen ganz
unterschiedlichen konstellationen da
mischt sich der bund nicht ein
insofern liegt die verantwortung hier
ganz eindeutig im landesverband
thüringen wo sind denn bei den
unterschiedlichen konstellationen die
sie angedeutet haben was die zukunft von
thüringen betrifft jetzt die roten
linien für die freien demokraten die
rote linie für die freien demokraten
insgesamt ist ja die die wir alle
deutlich gemacht haben als freiheitlich
beraten wir waren ja alle erschrocken
als wir gesehen haben was da passiert
ist
es muss ganz klar sein eine
zusammenarbeit mit verschieden
jan hoet mit der afg als partei kann es
nicht geben und wird es nicht geben das
weit wird unsere grundlinie bleiben und
ich glaube das ist mit dem heutigen tag
auch klar gestellt worden
in den wirren von erfurt hat sich eine
gewisse hilflosigkeit der parteien in
der politischen mitte gezeigt ist da so
viel orientierung verloren gegangen das
ist die demokratie selbst gefährdet ich
glaube dass die politischen landschaften
in den mitteleuropäischen papa den
mitteldeutschen bundesländern also das
was wir früher die neuen bundesländer
nannten dass es dort zu politischen
ergebnissen kommt dies enorm schwer
machen politik zu gestalten schauen sie
auch bodo ramelow wäre er gewählt worden
hätte nur eine minderheitsregierung zu
stande gebracht also mit anderen worten
es ist eine aufsplitterung des
parteienspektrums mit in ostdeutschland
viel stärkeren rändern als das in
westdeutschland der fall ist und das
macht es für alle politisch handeln denn
im moment wahnsinnig schwierig hier in
klaren kurs zu fahren
alexander graf lambsdorff vielen dank
für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
überraschung enttäuschung
sprachlosigkeit
nach dem gestrigen wahl paukenschlag im
erfurter landtag muss man sich ein
thüringer die ereignisse erst mal
verarbeiten
wir haben die menschen vor ort die
überraschende wahl des fdp kandidaten
und das mindestens ungewöhnliche manöver
der afg erlebt manuela konrad mit einem
stimmungsbild aus dem eichsfeld im
beschaulichen nordthüringen schauen die
menschen heute alle nach erfurt in ihrer
landeshauptstadt hier in nordhausen
leitet niels neu seine tiefbaufirma seit
20 jahren beschäftigt 40 mitarbeiter
thüringens wirtschaft brauche dringend
stabile verhältnisse und einen
ministerpräsidenten egal welchen sagt er
nun die diese hängepartie weiter
wenn jetzt in neuwahlen angesetzt werden
noch mehr zeit ins land gehen und die
dringenden aufgaben die wir in thüringen
haben breitbandausbau digitalisierung
einstellung von neuen polizisten
einstellung von lehrern beides berg
weiter auf der strecke also zufrieden
kann man mit der situation so dar
heiligenstadt im eichsfeld cdu-hochburg
bei der landtagswahl holte sie hier
46 der scherbenhaufen in erfurt wird die
menschen hier auf die nachricht vom
rückzug des fdp manns thomas kemmerich
trifft auf geteiltes echo
ja wenn so viel druck gemacht wird von
allen seiten ich weiß nicht ob man das
dann will wird das war dafür dass abend
von daher kann ich ihn verstehen ob es
richtig ist
also ich bin sehr froh dass der jetzt
gehört seit 24 stunden ministerpräsident
zurückgetreten ist also es steht alles
kopf man hat auch als wähler gar kein
vertrauen mehr
gerhard martin der bürgermeister von
unter einer 2000 seelen gemeinde seit 35
jahren cdu-mitglied ist geschockt von
dem treiben in erfurt geschockt von
seiner partei und fordert eine
kehrtwende
es kann ja nicht sein dass wir nach
diesem desaster so weitermachen wie
bisher das geht nicht
der freistaat ein gespaltenes land viele
thüringer hoffen dass nun baldige
neuwahlen kommen die endlich stabile
verhältnisse bringen und in jena begrüße
ich den demokratieforscher matthias
quendt guten abend guten abend
das beben von erfurt hat bisher nur
einen sieger die afd
geht die strategie der partei also auf
die strategie der afg und ihrer
vordenker geht auf sie haben den anderen
parteien der cdu und der fdp eine falle
gestellt
man muss aber auch sagen dass cdu und
fdp wissentlich in diese falle gelaufen
sind sie haben das in kauf genommen das
war lange vorbereitet und was wir hier
erleben ist wie eine rechtsradikale
partei die demokraten gegeneinander
ausspielt thüringen wurde zu einem
spielfeld mit dem ziel die demokratie
die
traditionellen liberalen demokratischen
parteien bundesweit vorzuführen und
diese auswirkungen die im moment noch
gar nicht absehbar sind sind sind
schwerwiegend das ist eine wirkliche
probe für die die partie für die partie
und wir werden noch lange daran knabbern
so jetzt habe ich bekam peter esser
wiedererkennt das ist schön ist die
demokratie denn ihrer ansicht nach durch
diese vorgänge schon beschädigt das
vertrauen in die demokratie und die
demokratische kultur das ist beschädigte
wir sehen dass es in thüringen sehr
schwer ist noch zu wissen wofür die
parteien eigentlich stehen die
bevölkerung ist verunsichert das sind
tausende auf die straßen gegangen
die kirchen die wirtschaft sind sind
empört auch international ist das echo
so und auf der anderen seite kann sich
die afg können sich die rechtsextremen
inszenieren
wir haben dem system ein schnippchen
geschlagen jetzt kommt wieder die
erzählungen von verschwörungen man macht
sich zum opfer von einem prozess der so
hätte nie stattfinden dürfen denn diese
strategien diese vorhaben diese die lust
an der zerstörung und vorführung des
demokratischen prozesses waren vorher
bekannt cdu und fdp hätten damit rechnen
müssen und hätten verantwortlich handeln
müssen und den rechtsextremen nicht
diese immensen geländegewinne zu belegen
dürfen bergwelt mit bitte um kurze
antwort das scheint ja alles auf
neuwahlen hinaus zu laufen ist das die
einzige möglichkeit nein das ist im
moment noch offen ist kann sich
minütlich ändern es kann aber durchaus
auch sein dass bodo ramelow und doch
noch wieder gewählt wird mit stimmen von
geläuterten cdu-abgeordneten zb das wird
sich in den nächsten tagen zeigen
welches verfahren jetzt eintritt vielen
dank für das gespräch nach jena es
könnte also doch noch den versuch geben
ohne neuwahlen zu einer stabilen
regierung zu kommen der ball dafür liegt
nicht zuletzt im feld der cdu in einer
stunde etwa gibt es dazu eine
pressekonferenz mit annegret kramp
karrenbauer und mike mohring in erfurt
es bleibt also spannend und alle
weiteren entwicklungen sehen sie immer
auf heute.de und später dann im heute
journal
vielen dank für
interesse